et bien notre invité qui va entrer lui
n'a pas la tentation de peau parce qu'il
y est mais il est aussi à Paris avec nos
François Bayrou et l'invité de questions
politiques
France Inter
question politique
Thomas negarov bonjour François Bayrou
bonjour merci d'être avec nous jusqu'à
13h en direct maire de Pau mais aussi au
commissaire au Plan et allié je crois
que je peux le dire encore au présent
d'Emmanuel Macron on va en parler
ensemble pendant un long moment François
Bayrou ce matin France Info a diffusé
une interview exclusive d'Elisabeth
borne fait lors de son déplacement dans
le Calvados c'était hier Julie Marie
Leconte journaliste politique de Radio
France lui a demandé si l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite était encore
négociable non ça n'est plus négociable
la retraite à 64 ans et l'accélération
de la réforme Touraine c'est de
compromis qui nous avons proposé après
avoir entendu des organisations
patronales et syndicales après avoir
échangé avec les différents groupes
parlementaires et je vous le dis
nécessaire pour assurer l'équilibre du
système je rappelle qu'on a eu trois
mois de concertation que le projet que
nous avions porté le président Emmanuel
Macron avait porté dans campagne projet
que nous avons porté dans la campagne
des législatives c'était de décaler cet
âge de départ à 65 ans donc je pense
qu'on a été à l'écoute et l'objectif
c'est d'assurer l'avenir de notre
système de retraite c'est à dire qu'il
soit à l'équilibre en 2030 alors non ce
n'est plus négociable ce n'est plus
négociable est-ce que vous pensez que à
deux jours d'une grande manifestation
avec une opinion publique est quand même
largement en défaveur de cette réforme
et notamment de l'âge de départ à 64 ans
c'est une bonne chose de dire cela
bon c'est le cœur de la réforme
si on disait que que la réforme ça n'est
plus le décalage pour cueillir plus de
personnes qui travaillent alors il y
aurait plus de réforme mais il me semble
qu'il y a une chose qui l'être important
de reprendre de rappeler
c'est la raison de cette réforme parce
que on se perd dans des considérations
et on oublie parfois l'essentiel c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
notre système de retraite et depuis très
longtemps en déficit extrêmement grave
même si on dissimule
c'est la lecture des chiffres le plan je
vous le rappelle rappeler les chiffres
précis que je vais faire devant vous et
personne n'a contredit ces chiffres
et on ne peut pas les contredire parce
que ce sont les chiffres même que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
rappelle dans ces annexes bon
ces chiffres sont ceux-ci
il y a un déficit de 30 milliards
d'euros toutes les ans 30 milliards
d'euros je rappelle à ceux qui
l'oublieraient ces 30 000 millions
d'euros tous les ans
c'est l'État qui apporte cette somme
pour arriver à un équilibre car les
chiffres repris habituellement ce sont
des chiffres après versement de 30
milliards de l'État 30 000 millions
d'euros tous les ans
et alors on dit bon ben c'est normal
l'État verse pour équilibrer
mais si l'État avait cet argent bon on
pourrait discuter on considère que ça va
que après tout on peut prendre cette
décision mais l'État n'a pas cet argent
ça n'est pas de l'argent que l'état
donne au système de retraite c'est de
l'argent que l'État emprunte tous les
ans
de sorte que l'équilibre du système de
retraite il est mis à la charge des
générations qui viennent
et un pays dans lequel les pensions des
plus âgées sont mis à la charge des plus
jeunes est un pays qui ne respecte pas
les règles morales élémentaires qui font
que une génération en place normalement
elle aide la génération suivante
c'est comme ça
sauf que je vais prendre un exemple
notre système de retraite par
répartition c'est les générations
d'aujourd'hui qui prennent en charge les
errations plus âgées donc ce nombre ne
fonctionne pas toujours
on vit sur une illusion on dit tout le
monde dit tout le monde se gargarise y
compris les responsables politiques et
les et les médias d'un système par
répartition système partition c'est un
système dans lequel ceux qui travaillent
paix pour ceux qui sont à la retraite
mais c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça
fonctionne je vous donne les chiffres
exacts le
les pensions la somme des pensions c'est
345 milliards
sur sur ces 345 milliards il y en a
qui ne viennent pas de la répartition
mais qui viennent de l'État pour deux
buts le premier c'est normal l'état
compense aux caisses de retraite les
efforts qu'ils demandent à faire par
exemple si je mets des trimestres
supplémentaires pour tel ou telle
catégorie familiale ou bien si je baisse
les charges des des salaires les plus
bas de la pyramide c'est normal l'état
dit fait ça il compense mais ce qui
n'est pas normal c'est que c'est le
l'équilibre même du système de retraite
l'équilibre financier du système de
retraite qui année après année et
financé par l'emprunt depuis des
décennies vous savez que j'ai je me suis
votre bataille sur cette idée de la
dette on se trouve aujourd'hui devant un
mur si on n'est pas capable de revenir à
cette raison élémentaire cette raison
élémentaire c'est celle qui veut que
ça veut dire qu'il faut supprimer le
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites parce que le corps me dit
quand même pas ça pour cette année pour
l'année prochaine mais il y a pas de
déficit c'est très facile de vérifier si
je peux faire une proposition simple
on demande une mission Flash
à la Cour des comptes et à l'INSEE
que en deux semaines et ça suffit
largement il regarde quelle est la
crédibilité des chiffres que le plan
avancé
parce que ce qui a plombé par des
expression le gouvernement notamment
dans sa dans toute sa volonté de
pédagogique c'est de nous dire que
c'était nécessaire juste il y avait pas
de perdant on reviendra sur les autres
termes nécessaires c'est ce qu'avait dit
Nicolas Sarkozy lors de la précédente il
manifestement tout le monde avait dit
d'accord aujourd'hui toute l'opposition
10 mais attendez c'est pas nécessaire
Laurent Berger
est allé jusqu'à donner d'autres pistes
de financement que celle de la réforme
des retraites comment voulez-vous que
les gens comprennent pas que ce sont des
chiffres qu'on manipule dans un sens ou
dans un hôtel vous avez complètement
raison
[Musique]
les temps en p143 sur les 143 il y a 25
milliards qui sont les cotisations de
retraite des fonctionnaires contractuels
ou pour l'État pour les collectivités
locales pour les hôpitaux il y en a 90
qui sont les compensations que
j'évoquais et il y en a 30 30 milliards
tous les ans mis à la charge des plus
jeunes et quand je pense que on essaie
de les de les engager à manifester alors
que c'est eux qui vont payer il y en a
quelque chose qu'on ne dit pas je ne
comprends pas bien pourquoi on ne le dit
pas au plus exactement je comprends
assez bien pour qu'on ne le dit pas
c'est parce que on veut pas ouvrir des
fronts et que le corps fonce à satisfait
tout le monde et lorsque le gouvernement
dit équilibre lorsqu'on dit 10 12 15
milliards ça n'est pas les déficits
actuels
ce sont les déficits prévisibles c'est
pourquoi il y a des scénarios qui disent
avec tant de croissance c'est un peu
plus un peu moins donc le la situation
réelle d'un système de retraite qui ne
s'équilibre que parce que l'État
emprunte tous les ans des dizaines de
milliards pour l'équilibrer participant
ainsi à la dette générale qui s'accumule
à un point
inquiétant ceci n'est pas n'est pas
beaucoup disent on leur remboursera
jamais c'est pas un souci alors on s'est
beaucoup endetté ces dernières années et
le stock on le laissera là où il est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça Françoise Fressoz
s'endetter quand on emprunte à 0%
c'est une chose
et prétendre qu'il ne faut pas de
réforme c'est aller à l'encontre des
règles élémentaires qui devraient élir
les générations ce qui devrait être dans
la rue aujourd'hui c'est ceux qui sont
au travail et les plus jeunes parce que
c'est à eux
comme c'est à leur charge qu'on met
l'ensemble du système de retraite alors
je reconnais que j'ai une position qui
est pas qui est pas reprise par tout le
monde
d'autant que si j'avais bien compris
vous étiez quand même assez critique
envers la réforme telle qu'elle était
proposée le diable est dans les détails
dites-vous il y a des choses à améliorer
elle est améliorable en revanche de
l'esprit à vous écouter on va même pas
assez loin je j'ai plaidé vous savez
pourquoi pour qu'on cherche ou qu'on
identifie d'autres sources de
financement que l'âge l'âge c'est
important ça l'âge c'est pour moi dans
les estimations que nous avons faites et
qui sont dans la note du plan qu'on peut
trouver sur plan.fr
l'âge c'est à aller à la louche grosse
louche une dizaine de milliards
ce qui permet au gouvernement de dire ça
sera équilibré
s'il ne considère que les déficits à
venir mais j'avais plaidé d'autres
choses le plus important pour moi c'est
le plein emploi le plus
l'augmentation de la production
oui mais l'effort général peut se fixer
cela comme objectif
le la productivité
j'ai même évoqué l'idée d'une légère
augmentation des cotisations patronales
pour que la réforme soit équilibrée un
ultra tabou pour le gouvernement mais
oui
non mais c'est vous voyez bien le
gouvernement une politique que je
comprends il dit on touche pas aux
impôts on touche pas au quotidien
qui contribue à bloquer énormément le
débat et à créer de la tension
sur le thème de la justice normal et
juste qu'un gouvernement est une ligne
de conduite est un axe pour sa politique
c'est pas moi qui vais dire le contraire
qui essaie d'avoir les mêmes axes depuis
depuis de longues années mais je dis que
la situation
d'endettement dans lesquels les régimes
de retraite jouent un rôle important et
inacceptable moralement pour le pays et
donc qu'on peut imaginer mes amis à
l'Assemblée ont imaginé de toucher
[Musique]
non oui
c'était pas ça
arrêtons-nous une seconde l'idée juste
terminer ce que vous avez commencé
l'idée qu'ils ont tous été que pour des
gens qui voudraient partir plus tôt il
pourrait envisager de travailler un peu
plus pendant leur vie active c'était
c'était une idée d'équilibre parce qu'il
y a des gens qui sont anxieux de partir
plus tôt et cependant on peut pas
toucher à l'équilibre des régimes comme
je l'expliquais et donc il doit être une
vision
je trouve pas d'autres mots que moral
éthique de dire on ne va pas accumuler
la dette du pays sur les épaules des
générations qui viennent pourquoi les
gens ils comprennent pas alors en gros
il y a 15 jours ou trois semaines le
gouvernement dit on n'a pas assez
expliqué on fait pas on a passé une
pédagogie depuis le fond de la pédagogie
ça change pas grand chose à se demander
si quand les gens regardent s'ils font
sur les simulateurs plus ils avancent
plus ils comprennent qu'ils vont être
perdants les femmes qui ont cru que ça
serait merveilleux c'est moins bien
qu'est-ce qui cloche les communications
disons la vérités
44 ans et que d'autres 43 ans
vous savez bien
nous avons vécu toute une longue époque
du pays dans lequel l'âge de la retraite
n'était pas calculée en fonction des
cotisations mais en fonction de l'âge ou
s'ouvrait le droit de partir à la
retraite mais tout ça va être j'en suis
sûr regardez par le débat l'assemblée
regardez par le débat au Sénat vous le
souhaitez la situation des femmes
on devrait avoir une règle de conduite
simple c'est que le le temps consacré à
la maternité ne peut pas être un
handicap pour la retraite on aurait pu
imaginer encore une autre politique qui
était ça aurait pu être un avantage mais
au moins au moins surtout dans un
contexte de ralentissement démographique
si vous voulez je vais je vais venir
dans une seconde mais Isabelle
mais il y a maintenant débat à
l'Assemblée nationale
le gouvernement est à la recherche d'un
accord d'un consensus tout ça va être et
le modem et le modem sera
le plus solidaire des parties de la
majorité
les publics les vous avez vu il y a eu
des études sur les votes probables des
groupes et on peut améliorer le texte et
être solidaire
aujourd'hui le député
par la réforme
[Musique]
je ne suis pas sûr vous l'avez eu entre
temps des conversations avec lui je ne
suis pas sûr
je pense que que en tout cas de tous les
groupes de la majorité celui qui paraît
aujourd'hui le plus soudé dans la
solidarité c'est le nôtre mais pourquoi
parce que vous voyez je viens de le je
viens de le dire il y a une raison
fondamentale civique
pour qu'il y ait une réforme des
retraites mais elle doit être le plus
juste possible et la plus équilibrée
possible et on y est par Ben vous voyez
bien qu'il y a des efforts qui sont fait
tous les jours et même le gouvernement
annonce qui va regarder la situation des
femmes disposition que
le plus en disant vraiment ça je
voudrais que cette amendement puisse
être
j'aime pas ce genre d'expression en tout
cas des conditions sinequatiques ce sont
des expressions de chantage alors
conditions sinequanone et je déteste le
chantage en politique c'est le rapport
de force vous avez expliqué récemment
rouge on est quand même un peu
bon c'était à une question de vos
confrères qui disait mais est-ce que
vous êtes assez entendu et ma réponse
était je ne je ne supplie pas jamais je
ne souhaite pas
demander ceci on demande pas on propose
et c'est cette vigueur de la discussion
que se trouve la solution
l'idée qu'on écrive dans la loi qu'on
fera un bilan la clause de revoyure je
sais pas pourquoi vous y êtes tellement
à cette clause pardon pourquoi vous y
tenez tellement à cette clause
je n'ai je n'ai aucun doute très forte
je peux revenir en arrière on s'aperçoit
que en réalité la gouvernance de notre
système de retraite comme de beaucoup
d'autres systèmes dans la société
française devrait être en temps réel
au lieu d'aller de crise en crise on
devrait être capable d'adaptation
permanente
de la part du commissaire au Plan et on
est plutôt dans le temps long avec
l'idée de voir loin et bien le temps
long voire loin se fixer des objectifs
et pour les atteindre des adaptations
permanentes si on s'aperçoit que ça ne
marche pas et d'un côté ça doit être il
doit y avoir une gouvernance et de
l'autre la capacité à envoyer
s'accorder sur le temps long si j'étais
le gouvernement comme on dit au café du
commerce
j'aurais
proposé volontiers c'était d'ailleurs le
cas de la réforme qui n'est pas allé à
son terme qui a été adopté et que je
trouvais intéressant et juste
celle qui a été abandonnée qui a été
votée qui a été voté la retraite à
points et que je défends comme c'était
en 2019
il devrait y avoir une gouvernance de
notre système de retraite qui s'inspire
de ce qui s'est fait pour le système de
retraite du privé agir que Arrco donc
une courgette
c'est un équilibre presque parfait
montrer qu'on pouvait arriver un
équilibre avec une gouvernance entre les
mains des partenaires sociaux et ce sont
les partenaires sociaux qui jour après
jour semaine après semaine
pour les indices ont pris les décisions
nécessaires pour que on arrive à
l'équilibre du système de retraite en
réalité c'est beaucoup plus intelligent
et beaucoup plus intéressant que d'avoir
un système qui nous envoie pour chaque
réforme d'une crise à une autre crise
d'un blocage un autre blocage d'une
révolte à un autre révolte vous disiez
Nathalie Saint-Cricq tout à l'heure que
sous Sarkozy tout le monde avait été
convaincu 14 manifestations
on disait la la comment dire les
critiques ne portaient pas sur la
nécessité de la réforme mais sur la
façon de la faire et sur la clause de
revoyure pas la clause de revoyure le
délai de décote était aussi poussé de 65
à 67 ans mais au moins vous n'avez pas
l'impression que la nécessité était
aussi forte alors close de voyeur
pourquoi le gouvernement ne veut pas de
Claude clause de revoyure
pourquoi alors vous avez dit pour
répondre à la question
je pense que on peut trouver un accord
réponse
à France Info elle dit il y aura une
clause de revoyure ça s'appelle les
élections présidentielles enfin
l'élection présidentielle
institutionnalisé
l'obligation d'un bilan
de la manière dont se passe la réforme
et peut-être une suggestion pour pour
arriver à trouver de nouveaux équilibres
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose c'est je vous l'ai dit la
situation des des femmes dont la
carrière a été
interrompu par une maternité qu'on
puisse tenir compte de manière plus
sérieuse
des trimestres qui sont aujourd'hui
alors c'est une subtilité pour
comprendre ils sont validés mais ils
sont pas cotisés
et donc il y a là une approche alors
c'est très compliqué dans le texte
aujourd'hui tout le monde essaie de
trouver le trouver le meilleur équilibre
possible pour moi
Elisabeth borne a raison de dire que la
situation de beaucoup de femmes ou d'un
nombre important des femmes est amélioré
par la réforme mais il me semble que la
situation des femmes ayant eu des
enfants ce qui nous ramène au sujet de
la démographie dont on va peut-être dire
un mot devrait être mieux pris en compte
une question quasiment de philosophie
politique dans deux jours on aura
peut-être 2 millions de personnes dans
la rue 3 millions etc à quel moment on
se dit que même si une réforme est
justifiée par les chiffres elle n'est
pas politiquement tenable
je suis persuadé que il n'y a de réforme
sérieuse que si une partie importante de
l'opinion
soit il y a des
soit considère que les inévitable parce
que évidemment ça n'est pas agréable
comme comme a dit je crois
ministre mais on peut considérer que
c'est indispensable et s'il y a un point
sur lequel on aurait dû avancer avec
l'opinion en partageant avec l'opinion
les éléments que j'ai décris devant vous
c'est précisément la situation qui est
faite au plus jeune en les surchargeants
de la dette des retraites mais pour
répondre à qui augmente tous les ans
ça d'accord on l'a dit depuis le début
de l'émission
ça n'a pas été prise en compte dans le
débat public non
parce qu'il y a une relativisation de la
charge de la dette je pense que c'est
très très important oui peut-être parce
que les chiffres partagent les choses
plus intéressantes plusieurs jours à
faire en ce moment il est de votre camp
enfin normalement
donc je vous laisse
pour les auditeurs
de manifestants dans les rues mardi
prochain les jours suivants à un moment
donné le gouvernement va être obligé de
réagir de le prendre en compte tous les
gouvernements sans exception sont
constamment en charge du lien avec le
pignon et ça ce jour comment est-ce que
c'est les sondages est-ce que c'est la
rue est-ce que c'est les actions ciblées
qui peut y avoir entre deux manifs
qu'est-ce qu'on va il va y en avoir 14
tous les 10 jours j'espère que non
j'espère que qu'on ne va pas en arriver
à une
institutionnalisation des blocages
qui seraient pour moi
pas si vite
antisynique j'ai été très choquée comme
beaucoup de gens de l'annonce que la
mairie de Paris allait fermer
maintenant le service de l'état civil
ouvert au service public impôts la
mairie sera ouverte et
apôt la mairie est ouverte que le maire
soit ou non d'accord avec les
gouvernements successifs il y a il y a
évidemment des moments où on peut avoir
des désaccords quand on est responsable
politique mais la charge
de
mère c'est qui est une fonction publique
qui est un service public celle-là ne
peut pas s'interrompre enfin pour moi
c'est évident mais est-ce que le
président Macron que vous connaissez
très bien à la capacité d'écouter ce qui
se passe dans la rue et donc de revenir
éventuellement sur son projet de loi
y a-t-il trop de verticalité dans cette
présentation de la réforme des retraites
alors le styles et les méthodes
pour le coup c'est vraiment de la
gouvernance ce sont des sujets de ce
sont des sujets de conversation éternel
c'est pas ça le président de la
République il a tenir compte de quoi
il a à tenir compte des nécessités de
justice dans la société qui lui a confié
cette charge
et j'ai dit ce qu'il en était entre
génération de de du déséquilibre et de
l'injustice entre génération
mais donc il a tenu compte de ça il a
tenir compte de la situation chiffrée et
il a tenir compte des engagements qu'il
a pris et il a tenir compte de l'opinion
c'est cet équilibre là comme président
de la République ce qui cherche c'est
pourquoi le le
la nécessité dans cette fonction
d'un équilibre avec une composante
morale aussi est très importante ce qui
est frappant quand même depuis le début
l'émission c'est que vous nous avez dit
qu'en fait le gouvernement pour ne pas
ouvrir de front c'est vos mots à vous
n'ont pas évoqué la question de la
charge de l'État permanent des 30
milliards
pour éviter préchauffer pour éviter
précisément d'ouvrir des fronts je suis
désolé j'ai l'impression que les fronts
ont été ouverts aussi donc est-ce qu'on
est pas en situation un peu ubuesque
vous dites le gouvernement n'a pas osé
dire la vérité et le résultat c'est que
il y a des gens dans la rue il a épousé
cette thèse selon laquelle les déficits
tous les anges jusqu'à maintenant
on les
on considérait qu'ils sont acquis et que
il faut se préoccuper des déficits à
venir
ma thèse à moi c'est qu'il faut se
préoccuper aussi à terme progressivement
avec le temps
calmement des déficits actuels que
tous les engrais la situation du pays en
augmentant tous les ans la dette du pays
de plusieurs centaines de milliards
parce que c'est c'est ça la situation il
y a un acteur dans ce conflit qui est
très important si Laurent Berger qui on
a promis de parler de démographie qui
souvent était en accompagnement des
réformes de retraite sur les durées de
cotisations et là qui ne veut aucune
mesure d'un sur l'âge légal sur les
durées cotisations est-ce que ça reporte
pas automatiquement Emmanuel Macron vers
la droite avec aucun soutien à gauche et
est-ce que c'est grave pour son
équilibre de
et de gauche et de droite ok vous êtes
attachés oui auquel pas seulement un
équilibre à deux et moi je suis pour le
pluralisme je pense qu'il y a une gauche
je pense qu'il y a une droite je pense
qu'il y a un centre je pense que c'est
ce centre-là qui au travers du temps
s'est vu confier les responsabilités du
pays ou en tout cas cette philosophie là
qui s'est vu confier les responsabilités
du pays dans l'équilibre politique ou
général de
des sensibilités françaises le courant
réformiste que vous évoquez
est absolument essentiel j'ai toujours
plaidé pour que
on comprenne qu'il y a dans un pays une
co-responsabilités
[Musique]
64 je bouge pas bon ça c'est des débats
sur sur
des éléments non parce que je suis
persuadé que si vous demandiez
Laurent Berger par exemple que vous
évoquez s'il faut une réforme des
retages je suis sûr qu'il irait
voilà mais bon
tout ceci n'est pas très étonnant il y a
un grand courant central en français
est-ce que justement le fait que Laurent
Berger n'a pu passer cette réforme en
tout cas ne soit pas neutre est-ce que
c'est pas un énorme handicap pour
l'évolution du Macron c'est ça le débat
public mais je répète nous sommes
co-responsables les politiques les
syndicalistes les partenaires sociaux et
les citoyens et l'opposition et les
oppositions quelle qu'elle soit elles
ont une responsabilité dans l'avenir du
pays en tout cas moi je plaide pour que
cette démocratie de co-responsabilité
elle soit reconnue
établie que l'on prenne l'habitude et ça
passe par le partage avec les Français
des éléments celui-ci qui justifie une
réforme est-ce que c'est responsable de
la part du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin de considérer que la
nuque donc l'opposition que vous appelez
de Bobo a travaillé avec avec le
gouvernement quand il dit qu'elle
bordélise la France il y a un peu de
vrais dans tout ça en tout cas que sa
volonté et de bloquer de paralyser cela
dit moi je faisais une réforme dans
laquelle il ne croit pas en sachant que
le terme vient de leur engager qui a dit
nous ne voulons pas bordéliser le pays
donc ce thème ce terme a été a été
repris et d'ailleurs ça devrait être le
cas l'Assemblée nationale aussi le débat
devrait devrait permettre d'examiner
chacun des points que nous voyons parce
que il y a beaucoup de zones à éclaircir
et donc ce
mais après chacun a son propre langage
ça n'est pas le mien je trouve que
alors
je vous disiez tout à l'heure
philosophie politique de mastégraphe
ambitieux c'est
utile puis il y a d'excellents profs de
philosophie j'en connais et donc
cette
réflexion là
quand vous êtes en situation de
responsabilité élue dans l'exécutif dans
le législatives ou dans l'opposition
quand vous êtes
vous devez prendre en compte ce que
disent les autres c'est très difficile
parce que c'est agaçant de voir des
blocages des manifestations des injures
des insultes
mais tout ça ça fait partie de
l'évolution du pays par exemple
fait partie de l'évolution du pays une
vision du travail qui est aujourd'hui
remise en cause par un certain nombre de
Français
ou un nombre certain de Français qui ont
le sentiment que
bon ce sont des charges ça va peser sur
les épaules ne plus perdre sa vie à la
gagner voilà et que moi il y en aurait
et mieux se serait je pense que ça
mérite un débat pourquoi est-ce que
beaucoup de gens sont
impatients de partir à la retraite parce
que le travail dont ils ont la charge ne
correspond plus à leurs attentes est-ce
qu'on a en France c'est un sujet très
important est-ce qu'on a en France
suffisamment d'évolution quand on est
dans une entreprise ou dans une
administration
dans le service public ou bien ce qu'à
la fin ça devient tellement routinier
que ça devient pesant et que le seul
horizon pour échapper à cette
usure là c'est la retraite le canot de
sauvetage dont parle le sociologue et
bien je suis complètement d'accord avec
cette idée en réalité le
l'obsession de la retraite et dans un
certain nombre de cas
une insatisfaction par rapport au
travail et si on s'attaquait à certains
satisfaction là alors je suis persuadé
que la question de la retraite prendrait
à notre visage c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a un point très important
dans le texte c'est qu'on est sur les
deux dernières années la possibilité de
prendre du temps partiel
en touchant une partie de la retraite et
en continuant à créer des droits pour
une autre partie
France Inter
[Musique]
hashtag question Paul François est avec
nous jusqu'à 13h sur France Inter vous
connaissez chat GPT c'est l'intelligence
artificielle
je lui ai posé une question j'écris
écris une question à François Bayrou et
il m'a répondu je vous jure que c'est
vrai quel est votre programme pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2027 et
comment comptez-vous rassembler les
électeurs pour remporter la victoire
c'est pas moi qui la pose hein
une réponse Tchad GPT on peut une
réponse
fermerez pas dans la question de
l'élection présidentielle en dépit des
efforts louables que vous faites j'ai
dit et je répète que c'est l'élection
majeure pour l'avenir du pays et que
tout citoyen doit s'y trouver engagé à
des degrés différents comme j'ai j'ai
affronté cette cette hydre trois fois
elle ne elle n'est pas pour moi
impressionnante c'est une bonne c'est un
bon souvenir les élections génial génial
parce que c'est cette
c'est des moments de communion tout d'un
coup
vous qui étiez un animateur politique
vous devenez le porteur d'aspiration
profonde
affective du destin
que chacun imagine pour ses enfants pour
soi-même et sa s'incarne dans un
candidat une candidate alors oui c'est
absolument comme expérience humaine
c'est absolument génial et comme
expérience de leadership c'est pas si
mal il faut quand même avoir le moral
pour faire ça non faut être enfin vous
l'avez et que certains vous appellent
François Bayonne ça vous aura perdu
c'est juste la réalité
c'est un président et juste moi mon chat
de répéter ma question juste très rapide
est-ce qu'il est pensable que Emmanuel
Macron retire sa réforme oui il est cuit
après
quelques responsables du pays y compris
le président de la République ne peut
pas considérer que cette réforme peut
être abandonnée
donc vous irez jusqu'au bout
donc donc
on peut pas considérer en conscience
et vous croyez que dans l'opposition les
oppositions raisonnables il y a des gens
qui pensent ça personne
il n'y reviennent jamais donc vous êtes
d'accord avec Elizabeth borne 64 ans
c'est non négociable pour revenir
à la question donc
j'aime beaucoup l'expression de mes amis
mais
il se trouve que que j'essaie je pense
que c'est le cœur de la réforme je pense
que la réforme est si on est un minimum
responsable je pense que la réforme est
inéluctable
je pense en effet que
une très grande partie des Français
n'ont pas compris quel était l'enjeu
pour eux-mêmes
et pour leurs enfants Françoise
on voit des soubresauts dans le paysage
politique notamment aux parties
socialiste alors je me souviens de
conversation très lointaine où vous
disiez au fond c'est parti gouvernement
PS
UMP à l'époque c'est vous à mourir parce
qu'il y a trop de contradictions
internes il n'y arriveront pas
au regard de cette grille de lecture
comment vous les analysez ce qui se
passe au Parti socialiste et plus
généralement sur la recomposition en
cours du paysage politique
ceux qui comptent pour un parti
politique c'est sa philosophie
certains disent idéologies
doctrine on peut trouver comment voit-il
le monde
et comment va-t-il son propre engagement
ce qui a de Claire partie socialiste et
qui a deux lignes depuis que c'est de
lignes sont même additionnées
ultra minoritaires dans le pays on l'a
vu avec le score de Madame dalgo moins
de 2%
et donc
ces lignes là elle ne rassemble pas elle
ne fédère pas il y en a une qui dit il
faut détruire le système et qui se
reconnaît dans la nupes version LFI et
il y en a une qui dit il faut être
réformiste et celle là c'est une ligne
avec laquelle je me sens profondément en
accord et ces deux lignes se retrouvent
à droite aussi d'une certaine manière et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'avais depuis longtemps analysé et
prédit que les deux tours jumelles qui
contrôlaient la totalité de la politique
française un jour s'écroulerait
vous êtes en train de dire au vu de ce
qu'on observe ces dernières semaines
le PS ne peut pas survivre s'il ne
trouve pas et n'impose pas une ligne
politique assise sur une philosophie
politique et une philosophie de l'action
et de la responsabilité le père se
présente comme un parti de gouvernement
il demande le retour à la retraite à 60
ans Alors qu'ils ont eux-mêmes voté la
fin de la retraite à 60 ans c'est eux
qui l'ont voté la réforme Touraine c'est
pas autre chose que ça avec des
modalités différentes c'est eux qui
l'ont voté ils demandent aujourd'hui
pour être dans le cadre de leur alliance
le retour à la retraite à 60 ans
c'est sérieux oui ce qui est une
hypocrisie est-ce que c'est sérieux
est-ce que c'est d'être un parti de
gouvernement et ben évidemment la
réponse à ces deux questions montre qui
sont devant une difficulté très
importante est-ce que selon vous le
rassemblement national est aujourd'hui
un parti de gouvernement
avec les positions qu'il prend non
aucune manière je pense que un certain
nombre d'entre rêvent que cette
évolution puisse se produire pour
l'instant non le les choix qu'ils ont
fait ne vont pas dans ce sens-là et puis
vous n'imaginez pas une victoire du
rassemblement national en 2027 c'est
inimaginable alors que c'est évoqué
beaucoup d'observateurs un peu plus loin
c'est très intéressant de regarder la
ligne politique
mais il n'y a pas seulement les pensées
il y a les arrières pensées
et dans les philosophies ou dans les
doctrines politiques dans les idéologies
il y a un certain nombre de sujets qu'on
caresses qu'on excite que de et les
sujets que l'extrême droite agite pour
moi sont des sujets de fractures de la
société française et donc ça ne peut pas
être pour moi un parti de gouvernement
vous pensez à l'immigration vous pensez
à quel autre sujet oui je pense je pense
à
l'excitation de la détestation à
l'intérieur de la société française de
religion d'origine de tous les sujets
qui qui touchent au vivre ensemble comme
on a l'habitude de dire Nathalie
internationale
en quoi est-ce que je pose la question
ou vous y allez tout seul
en quoi non mais en quoi la question
démographique est une et pour vous un
sujet essentiel quand on est notamment
en charge du plan et donc de l'avenir de
notre la question démographique en
France est un sujet vital
c'est pas vrai pour les autres pays je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
il y a deux aspects vous avez raison de
dire que il y a un certain nombre de
pays qui vont souffrir cruellement de ne
pas avoir d'enfants la Chine oui nouveau
850 000 va perdre presque l'équivalent
de la population européenne dans les 30
ans qui viennent et ça sans aucun
recours parce que les enfants sont
déjanés ou plus exactement pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ils ne sont pas ni
l'Allemagne un certain nombre de pays
européens sont en crise pourquoi parce
que le renouvellement des générations
c'est le la clé de la vitalité d'un pays
mais il y a un autre problème en France
c'est que tout notre système social est
assis sur la répartition pas seulement
les retraites
l'école gratuite pour tout le monde de
la maternelle à l'université presque la
santé gratuite pour tout le monde
l'assurance chômage pour tout le monde
l'Assurance retraite pour tout le monde
l'ensemble de notre contrat social en
France l'ensemble tous les sujets qui
sont à ce point difficile à porter tous
ces sujets là sont ainsi sur le rapport
entre le nombre des actifs et le nombre
des assujettis vous pensez qu'il faut
donc une politique nataliste je me porte
en France et de quelle nature il faut
une politique démographique
responsable qui favorise
le
renouvellement des générations est plus
encore et je vais vous en donner une
preuve et un exemple peut-être de
politique oui mais d'abord une preuve
on est en France descendu au-dessous des
deux enfants
par femme on est à 1,8 alors que le taux
de renouvellement de génération est à
deux grossièrement grosso modo c'est
très intéressant parce que là aussi on a
établi une étude du plan sur ce sujet
que on peut trouver sur le site
quand vous demandez aux femmes
quel est le nombre idéal d'enfants
qu'elle voudrait
et bien les études montrent de manière
indiscutable qu'elles en voudraient un
de plus que ce qu'elles ont
celle canon 1 envisage révolontiers d'en
avoir eu deux ou d'en avoir deux celle
qui a dans deux envisagent d'en avoir
trois toujours un de plus que ce
qu'elles ont pourquoi on leur laisse pas
cette liberté là pourquoi on les aide
pas
elle dit ça mais qu'elle n'en ont pas
vraiment envie et notamment dans vos
dans les chiffres qui sont donnés c'est
en partie aussi qu'on n'est pas en
dessous d'un 8 parce qu'il y a une
natalité plus vivace avec grâce à
l'immigration oui alors là aussi il va
falloir être clair sur ce qu'on veut
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas à la fois
considérer avec l'immigration c'est
quelque chose de très mal et se dire que
finalement ce sont c'est grâce à ça
qu'on est un peu plus moi je refuse de
de regarder notre pays comme coupé en
deux les Français de souche comme c'est
un disent et les autres qui dit il y a
une contribution très importante bien
sûr mais ça pas d'aujourd'hui que les
plus pauvres contribuent à la natalité
c'était on a même vécu des époques
entières dans lequel la fraction la plus
installée de la société avait un enfant
avec nous immigration qui va être cette
semaine
enfonçons ce clou là
il n'y a pour la France aucun avenir
comme
pays comme nation et aucun avenir comme
contrat social si nous restons avec cet
effondrement de la natalité là donc il
faut faire quoi et bien il faut une
politique
j'en ai cité tout à l'heure une que dans
le cadre de la carrière pour les
retraites on soit assuré que d'avoir un
enfant ça ne fait pas perdre des droits
vous voyez un peu les un peu les
changements que ça signifie ça veut dire
une politique de garde des enfants parce
que les femmes à juste titre il y avait
pas un seul
service public de la petite enfance qui
était prévu avec un droit opposable à la
gare de des petits c'est des choses
importantes pour vous ça quand on est
mer dans une ville j'ai encore eu deux
réunions cette semaine sur ce sujet dans
le cadre de la mairie d'Angers la charge
à Pau quand on est maire quand on est
responsable public oui on doit se sentir
en charge alors je crois que la forme de
de droite sacré mais le
c'est inacceptable qu'on se trouve
devant l'impossibilité de faire garder
un enfant dans le cadre que je viens de
dire dans le cadre national que je viens
de dire et donc
et ceci c'est pas du blabla vous
comprenez favoriser les gardes favoriser
les crèches favorisées des assistantes
maternelles leur permettre de
s'organiser pour ne pas être toute seule
avec les enfants faire des regroupements
des associations d'assistantes
maternelles ça c'est pas des politiques
abstraites il nous reste quelques
secondes et ça c'est pas très non plus
une toute petite question est-ce que
vous considérez qui risque d'avoir un
retournement de l'opinion vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine c'est-à-dire que on est en
train de basculer dans du l'offensif
avec la demande des chars
offensives alors qu'on était sur
l'hypothèse d'armes défensive est-ce que
ça a un sens le risque de devenir
cobelligérant est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'on est un tournant en quelques
secondes je pense aller dans notre
logique je pense qu'on est dans Le
Devoir qui est celui des pays de liberté
de ne pas accepter qu'un État puissant
se jette sur son état voisin réputé plus
faible pour l'annexer ça ça a donné des
guerres mondiales merci beaucoup et donc
notre de à nous c'est d'opposer la
solidarité des pays de liberté
une tentative insupportable sans ergoter
merci François Bayrou en tout cas
réfléchissant c'est pas allez ceci est
une politique d'équilibre nécessaire